the Joe Rogan experience it's got a
trigger scope yeah that Walking Dead
shows ridiculous he'd never runs out of
rows
never he never gets a pass through like
six years he's been in the zombie
apocalypse these are no soft you could
walk up to them stab them in the skull
your knife will go through their skull
no problem yeah by stabbing someone in
the skull that shit's hard
I have never it bounces off it's not
easier just try it just it's not easy to
you have to be really [ __ ] strong and
you got to hit a good spot the other his
soft spot your temp yeah but like he
just goes right through them with that
stupid arrow but then it never passes
through right never goes right through
and he just grabs it even have like
broadheads on he's got field tips those
those tips on his arrow they're like a
little tiny they'll make a pencil hole
like what that is is for practice right
practice tips on his [ __ ] arrows he
doesn't even have broad heads there's
some holes in these plot a lot of holes
that show I used to love I love that
show for the first few seasons yeah it
was a great show for like the first two
or three season I watched it up until
Rick the main guy left I didn't get that
far
and a little spoiler alert yeah when
they killed Glenn I was like I'm done
the day they killed Alan that was a
bummer but some way they did it to what
you guys got no respect to your main
character smashing his head and I saw
the dude who played Glenn I saw him out
somewhere I want to say it was out of
UFC he might have been out of UFC in the
crowd he was somewhere in the crowd but
he looked depressed Oh like he was
bummed out about getting killed though I
mean if you imagine if you're on a show
and you're one of the big players on the
show I mean he was one of the main guys
yeah and one of the more interesting
guys and he's on this show for five six
years or whatever it was and then one
day they just baseball bat you this new
guy yeah baseball bats you so not only
does this new guy on the show who's
getting all the heat but now he baseball
bats you to death yeah and then you're
just out there in public and probably
people are like mocking you on social
media if you're not smart you read
all bummed out and that was at the
height of its success like hey well now
I know you can't wait til Rick leaves
yeah well once Rick left it's dead right
I mean I mean there's kept it going but
I was on it now uh the chick with the
sword still there she was but she's
leaving soon didn't like what do you got
yeah because his sons gone too Rick son
Carl Carl Carl Carl huh yeah uh my buddy
Josh McDermitt is on there yes yeah Josh
Eugene yeah Josh was on the podcast like
early on the show like early and we're
like dude I can't believe you're on the
[ __ ] walking down I knew Josh from
way back in the day Josh worked with me
at the Tempe improv he was doing an open
mic contest I think on Thursday on
Wednesday or Thursday and then we went
we got in there early because we had to
do radio back then and Josh was onstage
he was really funny and I said hey man
you want to work with us all week yeah
he's like [ __ ] yeah and so he really
good guy and now I know he started I
mean that's his thing you just stand up
was he still doing stand-up not much not
much that sucks
yeah he because he has to be in Atlanta
so much but he's like play he could play
Bill Hicks in a movie oh yeah I've never
do a Bill Hicks movie especially with
that haircut the game perfect but he he
kind of went off the radar a little bit
cuz you know that the fans are so
fanatical that that he it was just like
a lot on Instagram and social media and
it was too much and he just went off all
that stuff oh did he really
hmm that's not good once you're done
though yeah doing the [ __ ] improv
again yeah I need that [ __ ] he's a
society's gonna be an actor now yeah you
might cuz he really loves acting but I
remember he couldn't tell anybody that
he had gotten the show yeah I remember
that and suddenly he had a mullet yeah
really I mean nothing I'm one too like
keynote
someone say everybody like dude yeah
this is beforethey of my the mullet cool
he kind of did but not really it's
really just a punchline he owns he owns
it he lives it
he is it he embodies it yeah is um is
but they didn't with Josh's mullet isn't
it um the hair is like glued on though
right it's like some crazy wig thing
they might put some pieces but he grew
it out and dyed it dark Wow and then he
then I was at a wedding with him when
the announcement came out of him I don't
know about the top part
yeah I think they glue a lot in there
some extensions he can he can rock that
[ __ ] look at the upper left-hand corner
that one will you curse was that oh
that's good that's like hot dude from
the eighties you know like a dude who
just pulls up in a Trans Am that's right
[Laughter]
[Applause]